here you go sabrina your buckwheat cake
with coconut butter almonds and nuts
strawberries and rhubarb sugar-free with
pistachios gluten-free no milk
derivatives enjoy your meal
nowadays eating isn't that simple
anymore wherever we go we are told to
eat certain foods and not others we are
told we eat too much some food is bad
for us some aren't ethical their
production and consumption are bad for
the environment we must worry about what
we eat as it's full of preservatives and
pesticides and that we should become
vegan
that it would be better if we eliminated
gluten
meat fish eggs sugars milk and all
processed food
all this creates a widespread fear and
confusion on our tables
between truth pseudoscience miracle
diets and new dogmas that questions the
traditional way we feed ourselves many
worried people are seeking solutions
through alternative and curious diets
i eat therefore i am
such a lovely surprise to find vegan
vegetarian and gluten-free dishes
let's say that we are very careful about
what intolerances and allergies might be
various way of eating so we must be up
to date on everything
there you find the 14 major allergies
included in the menu so you already see
what you may or not choose of course
bread is gluten free buckwheat bread and
two black rice crackers
it's not easy today to run a restaurant
there are many people like sabrina that
go through the menu searching for
ingredients they absolutely want to
avoid like gluten lactose but not only
as a main course we have eggplants and
spinach beets sauteed with parsley
i am much happier now and even feel free
to go out to lunch as finally there is
more awareness towards people with food
intolerances but also towards the
quality of food in general and compared
to the past now it's a pleasure to dine
out
sabrina is 54 and has been testing for
quite a while the reactions her body has
to certain food
since childhood the taste of meat has
always very much bothered me but also by
its smell since i was a child i must say
my mother as a good lumber made me try
all kinds of meat so i know exactly what
i'm missing out on and what i dislike
growing up as a personal choice cruelty
on animals define my definitive choice
to become a vegetarian
my choice of not getting completely rid
of gluten but being very careful about
it is based on physical well-being
the problem started when i noticed that
my abdomen had swollen which didn't mean
i was sealing or that i was suffering
from intolerances
i did exams for that
but mostly a reaction to some kind of
grains that aren't the ones of the past
healthy ones we had back in the days and
that's why i had these reactions
i feel much better metabolically less
weight less tired and fatigued
my doctor knows about my food
preferences and my blood exams are good
with no particular deficiencies
i also avoid corn wheat i eat very
little rye and barley because even if
they do contain gluten it's a much more
digestible one since i started eating
those i don't have metabolic problems
any longer and my stomach doesn't swell
anymore
while all the others that contain no
gluten at all like oats hermit brookweed
and rice i consume those regularly
i prefer not to eat processed food where
they sell gluten-free turnovers i prefer
to make them myself
i give myself a little time it's not so
time-consuming and complicated
[Music]
our lives are too frenetic there is the
time to do stuff it just takes 15 to 20
minutes the time to make good pasta
so gluten-free works
gluten-free forever again
um
for breakfast proteins oats and peanut
butter always
proteins carbs and fats it's a full meal
i digest it fast
i refilter oats if i take away the part
that remains more solid i blow less
breakfast of champions
some people have decided to eliminate
some food elements from the diet
others have created a customized diet
mikel is 24 and is an athlete
the meals that he prepares and eat
methodically spells out his days from
the morning to late at night
that rice is from last night at 2 am i
couldn't finish it at all
it will be today's entree
now i'm preparing chicken i'll season it
i will pull out the rice later
carrots and fennel as vegetables are
important
usually i start at 9am by preparing
breakfast as soon as i get up
i eat at 10 30 and then eat again at 13
30 to 14.
depending on how many carbs i'm eating
because if i am i'm sure i'll be hungry
much sooner than that
the meals are actually four with four
more snacks at least i prefer to cook
once every day and a half instead of
cooking all the time and stressing out
about it
eating shouldn't be a stress maybe now
i'll have three slices one way and three
in another so i don't get tired of it
during the day and have different
flavors
given that i eat just rice chicken eggs
carrots and other few things i must vary
tastes to keep my appetite stimulated
this is the most recurring adjective but
in the end they all come and ask me for
advice
so i probably am not that insane
if i eat anything different from my
usual diet i can immediately feel a
difference in my stomach that i can't
quite explain
it's like a weight and immediate
bloating
precisely one kilogram
now i'll divide it up
so i can know how more or less how much
i eat each time about 100 grams
i draw lines
just to not use a scale so i don't
stress out about
i it to cut up the chicken and mix it in
with all the rest so it becomes a single
course
it's not very nice to see but it's
practical
i never eat raw stuff i prefer to cook
everything i could eat carrots in my
salad for example or fennel but i don't
like raw vegetables and absolutely not
meat
i could never go back even if i wanted
it would be a problem to start eating at
someone's house again
when i'm invited to lunch i always eat
everything i like everything but when
food is too seasoned there is too much
oil or some uncooked butter it bothers
me and weighs me down
a repetitive diet that would annoy
others
but for mikhail it's the only possible
one
i think i'll keep eating this way
now i'd say i eat this way forever
because it makes me feel great
actually i feel great since i started
eating this way
i felt well before too but a different
kind of feeling
i wasn't as weird as i am now
even if i had always eaten healthy food
my mother and father always cook good
things
in the past
it was a fake well-being because i was
used to those circumstances
so you don't really know how you'd
possibly feel how energetic eating the
right food feel full of life basically
when you eat well you're full of
energies
what was it about half a kilogram of
rice
no it was like 100 grams
only
what is it the besumi that grows and
grows
exactly overcooked maybe with a little
more water than usual
i make a point of eating just pigs
horses cows
i just eat animals that weigh more than
myself but i can see you being a vegan
just once a week i'd give it a try
jose born in turin 44 years ago after
time spent between lisbon and london
decided to move to tesino with his
family in pursuit of a better quality of
life
i grew up with a mediterranean diet the
one we call mediterranean 40 years ago
meaning that 40 years ago we thought
margarine was healthy then we found out
it's worse compared to butter
in any case it was a strictly omnivorous
nutrition
where at the maximum opposite extreme we
arrived in london and ate frozen pizza
and hagen does every day
then we started research in asking
ourselves how we could live longer and
healthier and what kind of diet we
choose for our children in that case so
we approached veganism
not just vegan actually raw vegans they
cook nothing of what they eat
raw food is living food because in the
process of keeping food fresh that is by
not cooking
all nutritional values are kept alive
they haven't been cooked
i was thinking about making the dried
cabbage leaves as you asked and started
making the burger you should put the
sunflower in water
we use selected types of cooking
that are generally not considered
cooking we dry food temperature never
goes about 42 degrees in a ventilated
area as if they were dried in the sun
or we ferment by pickling and other food
alterations but not cooking
it's especially for their son leonardo
that they chose raw veganism
we thought it would be better for our
son to eat healthy food
also because we were getting worried of
all the additives animals are fed to to
grow so
to fast on our tables full of unhealthy
products
hormones pesticides
and so we decided that it was better to
eat all that is closer to nature
[Music]
not raw vegan it doesn't worry us much
if he will or will not become raw vegan
what we care about is to feed him the
healthiest food
this is an almonds and coconut pie and
here we have chocolate strawberry orange
the cream is made from cashews and fruit
if you could only find meats in the past
cheeses and traditional produce nowadays
a locarno and belzona markets vegan and
raw vegan specialties can be found as
well
showing many is a big curiosity about
these nutritional fats
[Music]
with a raw diet you feel the effects
immediately which can be lightness and
satiety at the same time you don't feel
tired and ready to sleep right after
eating you have more energy
[Laughter]
since we started changing to vegan diet
we are almost never ill
also leonardo is difficult he gets ill
this is very interesting as a lot of
moms normally say that when a child at
the kindergarten is ill all the kids are
home ill too
leonardo is always at school because
biological food and eating them raw we
must be very careful to avoid unnatural
pesticides contamination as much as we
can
this is delicious have you had it
already
no
it's the first time
right now the rub is very popular it's a
kind of bread loaf made with carrots and
flax seeds dried at 42 degrees
they dry for five to six hours then we
fill them with carrots apple vinegar
beets
and cashew cheese raw cheese that is
salad leaves depending on the season we
add a bit of fennel or olives it depends
this is very popular right now
the dishes in the raw vegan diet can be
very simple but if a little more
elaborated they can take quite a few
hours of preparation
tatiana spent entire days on this
activity that is almost a mission for
them
i'm happy when people eat with us even
if it's just for once or twice a week
twice a month to try our food
i'm happy they can eat healthy be vegan
for a change and find out about raw food
[Music]
i believe everyone's mentality is
shifting in 30 to 50 years there will be
many people eating vegan food
having always practiced a lot of sports
particularly biking even in my youth i
practice a lot of sports i was always
told that carbs are essential for
practicing sports for endurance
resistance
basically is the fuel
the carbs are fuel and i have always
eaten them for example fruit bread
cereal for breakfast
a plate
and for dinner yes proteins meat or fish
or vegetable protein lentils
an elite athlete since early age
journalists for fallen antonio ferretti
has recently discovered that some of his
nutrition rules that he had been living
by for years were not suitable for his
lifestyle any longer
and so it was required he changed some
habits
i'm almost 62 and especially in the last
three to four years i noticed i was
losing muscle tone
what we call lean body mass
i've always been quite skinny but i was
losing actual muscle
even biking every day
even for long circuits
i also enjoy cross-country skiing but
nonetheless i kept noticing muscles even
those in my legs were losing definition
then i met with various nutritionists
and all of them insisted on the fact
that especially at a certain age it's
important to eat proteins pretty much at
every meal
so starting from breakfast lunch there
should always be a protein especially
animal protein
proteins are usually quills eggs
i eat five
and a piece of guaca and some almonds
then i have some fruit and sometimes a
slice or two of bread
grills egg have the best taste a little
aroma to them
a bit spicy
it's a pleasure to eat them
i then heard from a nutritionist that
quill's eggs according to him have a
lighter impact on cholesterol
especially if eaten in the morning
i haven't actually verified it but they
are part of this diet and it's a
pleasure to eat them
me
with this change this change in my diet
after a few months i was feeling much
better again
i could actually feel my muscles again
even in my legs
they filled my pants better
i mean i eat a lot of meat but also a
lot of vegetables raw vegetables cooked
in the evening
i'd say that the largest part is made up
from vegetables
also because they explained to me that
the balance to maintain in this diet the
acid and the basic parts of the
nutrition
so these last two years i feel almost
younger
giving up animal proteins in the course
of time can have consequences
deficiencies especially i must say that
during my cyclist career when i was a
pro i had been attracted let's say
caught up in this kind of microbiotic
diet
very whole meal
with little meat
for a period of time when i was racing
practicing four or five hours a day i
tried to eat just whole meal
with no meat at all
and i almost became anemic
in fact i still carry some consequences
even now
my iron and ferritin are always at the
limit
now this is improving too but giving up
animal proteins can really bring to
consequences especially at my age
if you want to be still active and in
good shape
is
in milan we meet up with lorenza she has
made a very extreme choice in what she
chooses to eat by adopting a diet
described in a book by german author
arnold ariet who lived in ascona on
monteverrita at the beginning of the
1900s i become flutarian six to seven
years ago purely by accident
reading some pages on the internet i
kept seeing suggestions about meat so i
asked myself as a matter of fact i eat
very low meat
also not much fish
but i was curious to find out if they
were healthy or not
then i decided to find out who eric was
a doctor in the 18th century beginning
of the 1900s
and he had started healing people with a
fruitarian diet
at that point i tried to understand what
happened in this case
i told myself
if it heals
means it does no damage
so it detoxes helps to live a longer and
healthier life and a spirit of happiness
i already was following a vegan diet
i had eliminated also cereals and eggs
but i still ate greens
so i started this journey
not as an immediate change but slowly
eliminating pasta bread all the cereals
and it's been the greatest discovery of
my life
i really did consume a large quantity
i acquired a lightness and vitality that
i don't have before
after a period without them you don't
feel the need for them any longer
at the beginning everyone was kind of
worried as i lost a whole lot of weight
but as eric says first you dissolve your
body then you acquire it again
even my muscles dissolved
as they were polluted too
so they had to be created over again
that's exactly what happened
all eric says happened to me too
i lost a whole lot of weight and then i
recovered it all just like before
plants give us with their fruits that's
why us fruitarians eat also vegetable
fruits the vegetable fruits we consume
are all those fruits that contain seeds
eggplants tomatoes peppers zucchini
cucumbers etc
also olives and avocados that are fruits
containing fats because we needed to
we live eat those vegetables that are
only leafy like spinach cabbage
cauliflowers or
artichokes broccoli
asparagus fennel
those are plants that want to live
and then tubers like potatoes
those are full of starch we don't eat
them
my breakfast starts with an apple
and there are also apple itarians they
just eat apples that could be
problematic to relate with others
i live relating to others and it's
already hard to dine out as it is
if i start eating apples only everyone
will start avoiding me and throwing
apples at me
the real reasons of the fruitarian
revolutions are mostly ethical
humans are evolving so are also
understanding what is better for
themselves and the environment they live
in respecting everyone
the thing is not only health but respect
for themselves and all living creatures
so living creatures include animals and
plants too that's the most important
thing
lorenza is not alone in this choice and
to demonstrate it she is bringing us to
discover the first vegan fruitarian
restaurant in italy
this is a fruitarian pizza made with
plantain which is a green banana cooked
in the oven and then processed on top we
have raw veggies
[Music]
it's the one and only fruitarian
restaurant in italy there is a need to
offer and encourage people to think
about a way of eating that is not
specific to our species meaning it's not
natural to the human race
the experience that he acquired during
the years while making traditional
dishes has then brought the chef
fernando bruno to suggest a cuisine that
he feels closer to himself
being a vegan first and consequently a
fruitarian i decided to offer in my
restaurant an alternative cuisine
compared to the classic standards of
cuisine that uses animals or animal
derivatives because us italians we have
a great tradition of rotarian cuisine in
every region all the
this is a fruitarian tartar made with
only fruit it's made with jackfruit an
exotic fruit that is treated and
processed with sun-dried tomatoes
some fruits are extraordinary just take
a classic squash put it in the oven for
about 20 minutes not at a very high
temperature let's say around 150 degrees
the squash is cooked
and we can make the pulp into a cream
which can be used for different
preparations for example a tasty plate
of organic fettuccine with squash pulp
and organic sun-dried tomatoes is very
appreciated by fruitarians
[Music]
the season's fruit and vegetables but
also ingredients that come from afar
i discovered the ductile plenty
with which i can make first courses too
or even a pizza
that has nothing less going for it than
the classic flower pizza
well it's definitely healthier because
it's a fruit pizza
plenty is cooked in the oven
when it's black you peel it and then
blend it at high speed
then you can season it with extra virgin
olive oil the kind without stones
a pinch of pink himalayan salt
and then work it like it or pizza dough
same for bread you might want to make
canopies or pastries
i
amongst the clients some curious folk
and many converts
quality of food like meat or tuna fish
is poor has become more toxic
fish is full of heavy metals etc so
apart from the whole vegan debate we
need to consider the quality of food
that is not the same as in the past
food is high energy food nutritious
it charges you as it has a very high
vibrations it's just been pickled and
not treated
and it's so marvelous to see such
colorful plates full of life and real
proterean diet is for everyone of course
it takes some patience patients to cook
we should look back at the past and
rediscover what our mothers used to cook
all the time they spent cooking those
marvelous meals
[Music]
[Music]
my breakfast starts at 5 30 a.m
it lasts about half an hour i weigh
everything because knowing my caloric
intake during the whole day is essential
to me as my goal is to be in perfect
shape my body my appearance is my
business cards
simone is a personal trainer he's 44 and
eating is to him much more than just
feeding himself he's always refraining
from the pleasures of good food in order
to maintain fit and for a personal
research on the best possible diet to
follow
my diet is mostly natural full of greens
i follow the five servings at least five
meals a day i have my snacks which are
mostly a fruit according to the fruit
that is in season
my lunch is mostly protein so vegetables
and some proteins while i prefer to move
carbs to dinner time to reconcile sleep
i made food and education my lifestyle
because we are what we eat and therefore
by eating junk food as i like to say our
body would be similar to a garbage bin
caring about nutrition is essential for
people like simone who competes in
bodybuilding contests
i've tried numerous diets mostly because
i like to experiment for work to be able
to advise others which diet would best
suit the person's lifestyle
but also out of curiosity to see the
actual effectiveness it has
i also followed the paleo diet for a
while it was well known in my
environment
so many proteins and very small carb
quantities
obviously accompanied by fruit and
vegetables
i tried the hunting pig out a hunter's
diet where you eat a huge amount
apparel diet linked to the alkalinity of
the food
the zone diet
but just for a short period it was too
complex to follow i tried the blood type
diet the warrior diet
[Music]
nowadays i follow a nutrition richer in
carbs up to 60 percent 65
on 3 000 calories so a very large amount
of carbs
precisely because he has tried on
himself so many alternatives
he knows the strength and weaknesses of
them all
as a general rule those who decide to go
vegan do it mostly for consciousness
issues if a person
one of my pupils decides for it
i advise them to have a nutritionist
follow them
there have been problems especially with
people that have eliminated carbs
their muscle mass is eaten away
making it harder to reconstruct a muscle
tone because as soon as you give them a
little more calories they tend to put on
weight and they don't want that to
happen
people need to find their balance in
nutrition as we all have our own
personal relationship with food
with my job i try to help people find
their own balance which doesn't have to
be my own
mine is strictly tied to my job to the
competitions others they have other
necessities
[Music]
nowadays there are many food fats once
people turn vegan once raw vegans and
celiac even if they aren't actually
celiac there is a bit of everything
even i as a young girl tried many kinds
of diets as i wanted to see what would
work out for me
and it seems to me the best experience
is the one we try on ourselves
it's true there were times i was
single-minded
about 20 to 30 years ago and i ate
mostly raw and believed the science
behind raw nutrition and i actually did
have the benefits
of course when i became a nutritionist i
understood how well you can feel how
much better feeling free and eating a
very varied diet and all the unique
benefits it can bring to health
it's important for nutritional experts
like barbara nelde to warn the general
public of the joys and dangers of any
diet
there are a few famous american stars
that follow the vegan diet for instance
right now there is a boom of this diet
but thinking about when i was 20 30
years old there already was the boom of
the vegan and microbiotic diets
these are waves like waves of trends
that usually have nothing to do with the
real instinct of a person
clearly there are also new kinds of
obsessions fixations for example
orthorexia named by an american
physician a few years ago
it's not a term that is accepted by
general medicine yet
but it's a term used to describe those
that are totally obsessed with healthy
food
everything must be organic healthy
air has to be pure water must be pure
and distilled
no coffee sleeping early not smoking no
alcohol no getting upset
i've seen people this way i have
patients that without my approval would
never have a square of chocolate for
snack
they are so scared of a square of
chocolate that could be harmful
while i try my best to erase their fear
of food
with my patients i do the opposite
explaining that we have instincts also
of course things that don't grow in
nature but that we enjoy them because we
were brought up with those tastes
if we have little quantities of those
things without fear we can benefit from
them
fulfilling a mental desire or a
heartfelt one
of that slice of cake small piece of
cheese without exaggerating and freeing
ourselves from these obsessions
do
you